i love brody that's
yeah man one of a kind he just had a
birthday together did he really
yeah he's awesome i knew him for a while
we hired him on a
show called uh midnightly news to
warm up the audience like back in
[ __ ] back in the 90s or something did
you uh yeah he uh
one thing that i loved about him was
his i think he just always had this
ability like
to make you feel kind of he was such a
loner almost he was such like a scared
dude
but he always would like really kind of
go out of his way to kind of make you
feel included you know
um he man talk about
being a loving person but finding it
really hard i feel like to express
how your love in like normal ways and
stuff
yeah totally he was a warrior man i
can't i still cannot believe that it
that suicide it's just crazy how it just
i mean it sneaks in yeah like in an
instant almost
yeah it's sad and people
can't do it anymore yeah but i also get
it sometimes man
i get it but there's so like you have to
fight through these
the hard times because there is beauty
on the other side yeah
this is a really dark time right now
just in general
a lot of people are scared a lot of
people are losing
loved ones and don't know where there's
you know
other bills are going to get paid from
so it's really scary at this time but
you have to know that it
we will make it through this yeah and we
will have
your fun on the other side and there's
little things that come like as you get
older that are really beautiful
little things and it's just literally
like
catching you know tadpoles with your
kids or like
the wind on your hair like you know you
get an appreciation for
certain things getting a snack anything
something small
i know when you can really like sit
there like oh this grape tastes great
like yeah you're like in a place where
you're like you're taking a moment to
appreciate
a grape yeah it's like oh this is
different because
you're not like as wound up about the
world helpful
you're like david duchovny but i feel
like the x-files are on the inside
i'm telling you it is we all have to
figure out all this stuff going on
inside
it's so crazy bro how much crazy baggage
we carry man i know man
yeah and then i will swim in it i will
make a [ __ ]
swimming pool out of my baggage and then
dive right into i know when there's
tons of other things to go do people
like hey come get on this water slide
come get on this ferris wheel like i
just made this amazing swimming pool
with all my own [ __ ] yeah let's just
go in there for a while
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one